um the movie's really really bad uh it's
just so you know don't watch it it's oh
no actually do watch it it's one of
those it's so bad that you have to watch
it
when the the other main the main villain
is kristen wiig
and she's playing cheetah and and the
plot with
oh it's really bad by the way if you
don't want the spoiled [ __ ] you i'm
spoiling it
um kristen wiig they
they lifted the entire plot remember
batman returns michelle pfeiffer is like
oh you know she's a nerdy girl and show
she's down on her luck and then she
turns into catwoman and then she's all
like
sexy and batman if i recall correctly
she fell out of a window
yeah and then was licked by a magical
cat
look please yes that is what happened
but when you say it that way you make it
sound ridiculous
even as a kid i was like wow so we're
not even trying with this one right well
if you think that's nothing batman
returns look like citizen kane so that's
what she's the nerdy girl right oh i'm
nerdy oh i'm nerdy kristen wink
and then like you know this movie has
something called the from the wishing
stone
and then she wishes to be cool like gal
gadot and
uh or why is she considered not wait
this movie's supposed to take place in
the 80s right
correct and kristen wick clearly has
hair like sammy hagar and you're telling
me she's not cool in this movie she's
she's not the coolest chick in the movie
she's not but see
you know they did the typical like
they did the typical she's not cool
because she has glasses
like you would you would think the movie
was made in the 80s right
to be fair kristen wiig is also ugly
like oh she's super ugly
but then the whole point like the room
she's all that where you're gonna clean
her up and then go
wow to this girl it's perfect you did
this so like like michelle pfeiffer
michelle pfeiffer was [ __ ] smoking
hot right she was always happy so even
when they try to ugly her up you're like
okay she's hot why is she single with
like five cats didn't make any sense
in this movie you understand why she's
ugly but she makes a way she's like oh i
wish i was hot
and then men automatically swoon over
her
when she this is her being hot and they
swoon over her like being hot um
she's 47 by the way i also want to point
that by the way don't get me wrong no
she's not bad i was gonna say like if i
seen this chick at a party i'd [ __ ] her
like if she was interested right but
let's
but swooning like like a whole scene
where people go
wow calm down this is the cgi
oh no or a 200 million dollar movie oh
no that's
the cgi remember are we sure this isn't
a remake of labyrinth no it looks like
the
new cats movie like it's really really
bad also
i'm getting david bowie labyrinth vibes
from this dude the movie
is is just but like [ __ ] stupid these
movies where they go like from
you know uh you know dork to hot or
whatever
it's like those those premises never
work like you said michelle pfeiffer's
always been hot
um the chick from she's all that like in
the beginning parts of the movie i'm
going
okay but clearly this chick's hot like
there's not even
you know what i mean like they couldn't
even really disguise how hot that chick
was
rachel lee cook or whatever yeah yeah
they put glasses on in a ponytail oh
yeah
yeah yeah i remember and you're going
but she's hot though like
you know even the makeovers seem fine
whatever but you're looking out of the
whole movie going this chick's pretty
hot she might be a nerd but like
so you're telling me this chick looks
this good she's a nerd
she's poor she's an alcoholic father
this is a beautiful inn like how is
how is she not the most popular girl in
school
well the other the main the main bad guy
of the movie is is
you know pedro pascal from narcos and
mandalorian you know him
uh he's a good actor actually i think
he's a pretty decent actor he's good
yeah he was terrible in this movie and
it wasn't his fault the writing was
really bad probably the director was
probably bad
the director's woman oh so they uh so
the first one
the first one pat i think patricia
something i don't know what [ __ ] name
is
but the first wonder woman movie wasn't
bad and people like man how how did she
direct the first one
and it was so good and the second one be
so bad turns out people found out and
they looked into it
the first one was written by men zack
snyder and like two other people wrote
the first one
they gave it to her but only under the
pretense that she would also write the
second one
so it was mike when i tell you
childish in the image of comic books for
kids right
but not child just like in a comic book
kind of way but just like
a dumb woman who doesn't understand it
so pedro pascal plays max lord right
max lord that's his name don't think too
much about it
fine have to move it's like women have
an infantile and
narcissistic and childlike view of the
world because
they've lived in a life of no
responsibility but anyway after half of
the movie
he's speaking with his hispanic accent
because he really does have hispanic
accent he's actually hispanic
but then just halfway through the movie
he starts speaking not in the act it
just goes away right
but let me just show you something just
to show you who do you think they were
basing him off of when i show you the
picture
who do you think the main bad guy is
supposed to be based off of mike
huh huh who does that look like t
who does that look like to you
pat sajak no it's actually trump
he doesn't look like he does like fate
sage bets
so drunk could have probably gotten pat
sajak and it would have been way cheaper
so there's a wishing stone and there's a
scene in the movie with a wishing stone
where basically he he he gets the power
of the wishing stone and he get granted
he wishes he gets in the white house and
it's reagan
and he asked reagan oh i'll give you any
wish what do you want and
what do you think reagan wishes for if
ronald reagan 194 what do you think he
wishes for
he could have anything think about like
like a genie but without the rules he
could have
anything in the world well i guess i
just wish i could keep my brain
sharp forever nope i want to keep my
wits about me till the very end
no you know what he wished for mike more
nukes
that's what what's a woman writes can i
be honest yeah
ladies just stop t no more stop writing
stop doing this
it's women are just
you again maybe it's a life of
not having any responsibility or
accountability
that you guys end up not had like like
people
write from their own perspective even
when they're writing a character that's
not like them
generally speaking when you're writing a
character you go
how would this character react to this
situation and then you look back and go
well this is how i would react to this
situation but i'm not the character and
then you go
have an area to work off of women are
just like i don't know
orange man bad we're gonna do orange man
bad
girl woman good girl power orange man
bad nukes what's bad what's a bad thing
he could wish for
nukes more nukes what by the way what a
[ __ ]
waste of of a [ __ ] of a wish from a
genie
the president i want more nukes you just
call [ __ ] uh uh
lockheed martin or whatever they would
have made unlimited i want more nukes
oh by the way you stay here i have a
better wish for you yeah just make me
more nukes please
like this oh my god so one more thing
and i have a
minute review if you want to watch it
but one more thing i did want to bring
up with you and this isn't a joke
wonder woman
somebody in the movie and i and i know
you're thinking that sounds crazy
yes nice nice sorry hey hey
look i'm not complaining here i'm not
saying it was but my point is if a man
would have
if a male superhero would have done what
wonder woman did it'd be a big [ __ ]
issue
so apparently the first her [ __ ] love
interest was in world war one and the
first movie dies in the first movie
she gets the wishing stone wonder woman
does and she wishes that he would come
back
but he doesn't by the way he could have
just magically appeared
at this point this movie has based in no
reality but anyway
but but what happens is his
consciousness gets downloaded into
some random guy who lives in the 1984.
some normal dude who's just like a
normal guy with a life in an apartment
and her brain her brain
takes her his uh this dude
chris pine's brain takes over this
dude's body
and then she just without and she knows
it like she knows it's a different
person it looks like a different person
except to her she just goes and [ __ ]
the guy she just [ __ ] him
she just [ __ ] this random dude and
wakes up in the morning she's like oh
yeah i just [ __ ] you and there's never
like a scene where like
hey didn't we just steal this guy's life
like this guy had a family and a life
and
now i'm just [ __ ] this dude to be
fair it's good though i mean i'd [ __ ]
listen you know i agree with you a plate
of canisius listen
you know i agree with you right i'm not
saying that but it's that whole thing
like oh yeah
t you know it's a word that if uh it's
that whole when the teacher [ __ ] a kid
kind of thing it's not yeah but it's not
because it's not a kid right no but the
guy did had no
say the guy didn't know what was
happening but you can't guys
that's the only only men can bother men
fair enough
so there's no time in the world like
that a
woman has ever demanded did this woman
women have had to do some convincing
but a guy's like that right my point is
is that if there was a dude and there
was the same story and a girl like
just ran they'd be like that man he that
woman like the dude had no consent
what if he was a gay guy what if he was
a gay guy
you can't rip a grown man okay because
either
i could [ __ ] say no or bash your
[ __ ] brains in like
he's just well i know it's wonder woman
but still maybe i'll make an exception
in this case because it is wonder woman
and you can't bash your brains in
but what realistic scenario is a woman
going around
but i can't kill you with my bare hands
but again my point is
my whole point is my point is the double
standard
that's all that was my only point that's
your big point when watching wonder
woman ragnarok
noah's [ __ ] ragnarok
that's the name of the thor movie no
this is wonder woman 1980 i saw the
commercial wonder woman ragnarok
wonder woman ragnarok that's what it
looked like to me
i just was like i have no interest in
this
wonder woman infinity stone like you
don't like that one
it's it's just gone
sorry i just don't i don't see the uh i
don't see it man
[ __ ] i i don't see i i will give you i
will concede
the double standard and i will say
wonder woman may be the only woman who
can
a man oh but then again it's gal gadot
um
frank says royce you cried over end game
spoilers now you say they don't matter
complete
i said at the beginning i'm going to
spoil it so first off i said i'm going
to spoil it secondly
don't compare [ __ ] end game to this
[ __ ]
pile of horseshit that they released on
hbo because of it because
cove had saved this movie's life because
if this movie would have [ __ ] come
out in theaters it would have [ __ ]
bombed yeah uh i mean i yeah i get it
i just oh [ __ ] i'm glad it was spoiled
how about that that movie's [ __ ]
terrible i say i saved you
i saved you two and a half hours
of your life yeah i wouldn't have done
that but that's
that two and a half hours to watch by
the way
any single solo superhero movie
that's way too good it's too long and
avengers i get it because there's a
bunch of people
but you're right when it's just one
person even avengers shouldn't be that
long because it's
most of that movie is establishing shots
and most of that movie is them posing
together
for the trailer and then like it's it's
every avengers movie is the same [ __ ]
thing
oh [ __ ] man you know bruce is trying to
not be hulk anymore
so we're not gonna have hulk the whole
movie wink
yeah sure sucks we're not gonna have a
hulk the whole movie wink wink
and then they all gotta oh boy now
there's tension on the team
how are these how is the team gonna
overcome their differences again for the
10 millionth time
and then oh boy i'll tell you what's not
going to happen though
we're not going to let hulk we're not
going to unleash the hulk because he's
too powerful wink wink
and then what happens they overcome and
resolve their differences
and then the hulk comes out for the last
10 minutes because that's all the money
they have left in the budget for hulk
it's the same [ __ ] movie every time
pam
oh let's all pit let's all do [ __ ]
poses back to back like a bunch of
[ __ ]
i'm so sick of these movies it's been 20
years of avengers movie
stop letting corporate america squeeze
every [ __ ] dollar out of the same
[ __ ] premise well that's
that's the thing at least you know i i
mean i obviously didn't pay to watch it
because
i have hbo max and it just came out for
you know came out on hbo max
i've actually been watching hbo max to
watch old curb episodes
and old whose lines um which at this
point hbo max might have better stuff
the [ __ ] netflix does
uh because you know it still has the
sopranos and has the wire i mean any all
the old hbo shows are on there as well
west world all the hbo shows are on
there so
uh better than any better mostly than
stuff on netflix and netflix on january
1st
is losing the office like they're losing
a bunch of mbc properties
because nbc has the peacock streaming
thing now
which is it just pay for cables just pay
for cable is that a pay thing
yeah yeah by the way this whole cutting
the cord thing that was supposed to save
you tons of money is gonna end up making
it like
decentralized and you're just gonna have
to pay for 90 different services
or you know just acquire things you can
always just
acquire them by the way you know what i
just acquired
recently and i didn't even know this was
out there 1995
96 97 98 monday nitro
all in one [ __ ] pack really oh yeah i
was like okay
this will be a nice sign a little time
killer i have the law i have a login for
the wwe network and they have all of
those yeah that's great but
the problem you're right it sounds great
sort of but the problem with them is a
couple things
they're edited excuse me they're edited
in um
any of me any like music that they
didn't have the like you know hulk's uh
hendrix theme when he comes out as a
hollywood hogan
like they edited that out to generic
rock music generic rock music
they love everything it's terrible yeah
this is it's no it's awful they do it
with ecw too
because ecw just used like any music
they felt like
and they just didn't pay anybody and um
yeah they you're right they dub
everything over and they they sweeten
the crowd
they've adjusted so much [ __ ] that it's
it's you're ruining it
i just want to watch the original stuff
but um
yeah it's the only good thing about the
wwe network i mean that their
programming is absolutely
trash but they the smart thing vince did
was buy
every tape library ever so you can watch
all the old stuff but
yeah i just acquired um the nitros
which is uh good stuff because i'm doing
uh dark fox's show next week
how's he doing haven't talked to him
he's good he's good he does a wrestling
show and
um he wanted me to be on it and we're
going to be watching uh
we're doing world war world war 396.
nice
where they just threw them all in a ring
like every [ __ ] wrestler in three
rings and it was
and they had five commentary teams and
it was just the best it was such a [ __ ]
show
all right uh let's uh let me read some
of these and then we'll uh we'll get
into some other stuff
uh but i guess i just wanted to point
out there's a whole 40 minute review i
did of the stupid wonderful movie just
you know i would still recommend
watching because it's bad